we talked about video games today and
let's say let's talk about something
else for the second Chris waters you're
here you watch some movies over the
weekend i watch some movie films over
the weekend Peter Brown has been known
to watch movie that isn't an amazing and
the Oscars are on pretty soon
nominations of Commerce not without a
little degree of controversy as well
we'll get to that later yeah but first
of all I want to talk about this is kind
of like what we talked about around the
office when we're not talking about
games it's Nestle this time of year so
Oscar season right what are the movies
that are nominated in Best Picture what
are the ones we think are good and i
always find this interesting because the
Oscar is especially best films always
this weird mix of oh yeah of course and
what is that like I've never heard of it
before so that's good Andrew the list
and see which of these movies sort of
lettuce on fire first one up mad max
fury road george miller's long time
coming mad max equal you know whenever
you try and go back and make a new
version of an old movie or of an old
series it's always you know super risky
business this is like easily the best
man maximum fear for me so good Chris
what you think I I love that movie I
mean I I like to go to the movies I
don't do it terribly often um but I
don't like i'm not a dude who ever like
watches a movie twice right I don't go
to the theater multiple times and I
don't like I don't own a lot of blu-rays
I don't like ask for them for gifts or
anything but I asked for Mad Max this
year fury road because I was like I need
to see this movie again and I need to be
able to watch it again and again because
it was just like so vivid and alive and
breathtaking and like intriguing
throughout like every frame and I it lit
me on fire when I saw it in the theater
and I I watched it over the holiday
break again and it's oh seok it's super
dense they always say the movies that
make all that really big money like
that's crazy star wars money are ones
that get off multiple viewing and I saw
this twice in the cinema as well at
Peter you found my max I thought it was
amazing I mean I it's not mad max movies
growing up as a kid and they were always
kind of this kitschy thing that you kept
in the background like oh yeah remember
those
is this was like guess what this is what
Mad Max should have been all along and
it was as you said dense you took the
words out of my mouth it dense with
characters wonderful cinematography
wonderful sets there was only a few
things that bothered me and even then
there's like it just took another like
scene change for me to forget all about
all right um I thought it was amazing
and yeah I've seen it multiple times and
I think it should just exist in
isolation I don't know that I want any
more yeah well it doesn't seem like
you're gonna get any regular yeah Miller
subsequently come out and said that
plans to do the two other ones are now
not happening but yeah but I think this
movie should exist on its own and just
be this great awesome nope yeah looking
forward to showing this to my kids in 20
years from now and saying the CIA that's
what they said the world would be like
and here we are and next one up looking
back to the past Brooklyn I'm guessing
I'm the only one that's seen this Danny
I haven't seen it it's in this what's
Brooklyn Brooklyn is a saoirse ronan or
swear say if you're an American reading
her name it's a story of this girl who
like a familiar tale for me a girl who
moves from actually a town that's about
20 miles from where I grew up in Wexford
moves to Brazil at all towns in Ireland
it's her experience sort of moving to
America feeling homesick going home
falling in love and it's it's a it was a
wonderful i really enjoyed this movie
not just because the creators of which
amanda Posey and Finola Dwyer shed at
the clan and not that clan and not just
because if it's a super great irish
movie or a movie about Ireland so many
ways but it's a it's a really
fascinating sort of timepiece I love
movies that really capture old time as
well and I've actually ever been to New
York of my life so I can't say that it
captured New York retary well but life
in Ireland and the Irish scenes for me
was completely spot on to watch I
remember and what I remember people
telling me a badge my parents single so
this is like a 1900s yes this is like 19
I want to say 50s okay yeah sort of that
immigration immigrant most war yes I've
ever had time yeah super good I enjoyed
it a lot I've actually surprised to see
it though to be completely honest and on
this i thought it was sort of like just
one of those good movies that won't get
recognized
side of it and so moving off not I guess
to something that I'm guessing we've all
seen the Martian mm-hmm you seen it all
right Peter what you think of Martian
Matt Damon on a marsh spoilers there's
no Martians maybe it was the character
that I built on my head when I was
reading the book but Matt Damon's
portrayal of the lead character I can't
members name now Johnny Martian Johnny
Marsh just I just really kind of rubbed
me the wrong way all right i'm not
getting best picture vibe from this film
at all hmm I from the list just looking
at it before this I didn't realize that
it was nominated I don't think it should
be yeah I thought his portrayal was not
great I thought the film didn't focus on
enough things in the book that made an
interesting read for me right which was
the sort of thought process he's at the
that he went through out okay how do I
fix things how do I make this happen
Matt Damon was like huh I got it no
problem you know like you see that as a
dink dink dink like just like like okay
I get it you're dislike charming clever
dude but what about the struggle you're
going through like there were a couple
mishaps that threw him off is you know
his comfy chair but like like really
like that's all the struggle you're
going to go through during this entire
journey just didn't it didn't didn't hit
me Chris I remember where you were
talking about it bet the process really
worked in that movie I like it was a
great movie about the scientific method
as much as it was about the reality of
what was happening yeah that's why you
like that movie I like I was drawn to
that movie and I haven't I hadn't read
the books so my perspective was a little
different than Peters and I think that
it is a movie that like it's really cool
that he's just like shoveling a bunch of
poop and then putting a bunch of poop on
the floor like that's not a heroic act
but it this movie makes it feel like it
it makes it feel like okay like writing
a you know how many like teri chicken
teriyaki dinners you got out on a
whiteboard like that's a smart thing
that a person does and I think so much
of science and so much of that kind of
expertise that has led to the world that
we live in in so many ways is like is
kind of boring you know like when you
look at it on the face of it it's like a
lot of like process work a lot of
grinding through and so I think the
Martian did a great job of distilling
that in a way where it kind of honors
those otherwise sort of seemingly
mundane actions
and elevates them because of the setting
and to me the setting was one of the
standouts I mean I'm not a guy who like
looks at pictures that the rover sends
back from Mars and is like dude dude I
love that school like they look cool and
I'm interested like on an intellectual
level but the like vistas that the
visual effects team created for the
Martian made that planet look like
fascinating and intriguing and
foreboding and beautiful to me in a way
that you know actual pictures of it
haven't which is fine it's movie magic
but like I don't know I felt that pull
and I felt that connection with like our
actual space efforts hmm um you know
despite the fact that it ends on this
like crazy rocket ship sequence do that
I'm going out and get him like you know
it it does those action movie tropes and
it falls into that in a way that I think
was ended up being off-putting for you I
I mean I got a lot of people in the chat
sort of echoing not as well the way so
it's like I kind of feel the same way
that it's it's a really great like I
really enjoy watching it but it just
doesn't feel like it's like one of the
seven best movie city here just like a
great use case in terms of how to film
that type of process like wow like how
the hell did you make growing vegetables
interesting another way there were
subtleties in the book that it just cool
and it sound like such it like any like
anyone talkin about in your book made
into a movie ever but they but they
totally glossa jit they totally glossed
over like the the finer points of his
journey to present this like this matt
damon yeah mm-hmm alright let's talk
about a different book has anyone read
or seen is that the rumor room it's room
to room the room is that tommy was our
thing that's a different situation bro
forks at the screen and have any of you
read the book no I heard about the book
and was when it was getting a lot of
press and I was really intrigued by it
yeah that's why I wanted to see the
movie I saw it yesterday actually I've
seen it as well but I have not read the
book okay what was your experience of
which thing when I getting into spoilers
again cuz there's another one this well
I don't know cuz if you look at a
trailer like do you consider what's
shown in the trailer spoilers maybe
because we're showing it right now sure
alright so yet you see in the trailer
that like the premise of this movie is
that there's this woman and her
child and they're there they've been
she's been abducted they are trapped in
a room yeah I can't get out that's their
whole world and then they do get out so
the movie is about like the movie covers
both scenarios yes is it before and
after and ah man is it so fascinating
the way like what if you had to raise a
child like this child the only thing
they know about the world is this room
yeah like you that's why that's why the
fact that the book in the movie or
titled room it's like Earth yes like
it's not like raw like this is Earth
this is room like this is all of
existence yeah and they talk of the way
that like you see through the mom and
through the kid they're like world she's
had to create and then the way that he's
interpreted the world and the way that
he's built his world like it's amazing
and then how he has to deal with oh no
it's like Plato's cave basically it's
like oh it's not just the shadows
dancing on the wall this is the world
and how does your brain compensate for
that how do you figure that out yeah
once he's out and then all of a sudden
like the world is it more of a reality
and like he's squinting all the time and
that makes you think they know there's a
scene with a doctor and you're like oh
my god like yes like this kid seems
totally like normal and functional but
what if what it like he hasn't been
exposed to germs or lamb bearing to like
there's only one source of natural light
in his house and he thought that
television was like this weird ethereal
place where everything but didn't exist
like it was all it was all cartoons I
thought that that kid did such a
fantastic job yeah great idea throughout
that whole movie and I think brie Larson
who also got the nominated for Best
Actress I think she did a good job I
feel like it's a kind of a soft
nomination for Best Actress because what
you really see like the times that you
really see like she shows you her
struggle in some ways but then in the
latter half of the movie where you're
seeing the adjustment to the world
outside and you're really seeing it
through the kids eyes yeah a lot I mean
the work was mostly apparently told
through the kids off yeah and they're so
you don't release you hear his internal
monologue and so I think that like I
don't you know i'm not sure about that
Best Actress nomination but like that
for best picture I think that it's like
such a fascinating drama
such an intriguing story and that comes
from the adaptation but yeah that was it
I was a stand up for me I we need to get
through a couple of more these as well
has anyone seen bridge of spies no not
Tom Hanks Steven Spielberg it's like
okay the time is the movie of course
getting an elimination it kind of feels
like that my wife saw it and she was not
a fan right but like it does I mean I
don't really know what it's about I'm
sure that's a perfectly fine drama or
man bon entertaining entertaining wise
planes crashing apparently the ejecting
from Tom Hanks castaway lands on it no
he's all right don't worry about Wilson
gets promoted to general let us know in
the comments what you think of frigid
spies done since we we don't have any
experts on a battle here and mr. album a
movie I think did you see over the
weekend the revenants you did a double
bill of room and revenant I did tough
afternoon the OL antsy I haven't seen
revin I tried to catch it over the
weekend and couldn't unfortunately I
have you haven't seen it either Peter of
you know I've seen it oh you've seen it
okay perfect Mary's outside and last
week was talking a lot of bad as well
she was interested in it but had sir
critiques as well Peter first of all
them what did you think of the revenue
um the easiest way for me to
characterize it is that it's half an
hour shorter than the cut of hateful
eight that I saw okay felt at least an
hour longer okay I I was less impressed
with the film than than I had hoped the
the constant struggle that DiCaprio's
character is going through begins to
like not wear on you because he's
struggling but because it's like I feel
like I just watched that scene like they
change the the setting they changed the
problem is dealing with but it's still
the same kind of issue like he's not
getting to where he needs to get em and
then I thought the resolution in the
third act just came way too fast and the
payoff wasn't there for me the thing I
had been waiting for was a letdown I'm
Chris you came away from her thinking
like oh this is a really beautifully
shot movie but again it yeah but you're
in the beautiful wilds of Canada how I
mean like yeah it's not that hard to
make that area seem beautiful on that
note just a quick sidebar like I was
looking at the nominees for Best
Cinematography of course the revenant is
one I watched another one of those
again sicario oh yes about the border
and the drug war between us and Mexico
yes anything the cinematography and like
you want to take like banff national
park and make it look beautiful no
problem we want to take the mexican
border at juarez that has like shanty
towns on one side prefab houses on the
other and a big ugly a steel wall images
and make that look beautiful and like
menacing but intriguing and like
foreboding in all these wonderful ways
sicario does that and like it it was a
great watch for end up to cinematography
was so sadly sadly not nominated for is
emma bunton as well yes she was uh yeah
didn't get a whole lot of nominations
Muslim or production related but back to
the revenant ah I feel like this is one
of those nominations where they're like
man you guys went out into the snow and
acted a lot that must have been real
hard grunting here's your nomination
like Leo DiCaprio his performance in
that I have no doubt that was very
difficult for him and no no doubt that
was taxing for him as an actor but like
he plays an animal throughout the whole
thing right he's not a human because
he's so messed up that he is like debase
to his basic survival in yes which is
fine that's a it's a certain kind of
narrative but a survival story neat like
you need tension mmm for it to really
hit home and never what did I doubt that
he was gonna survive until the epitome
okay well let's come on not only halfway
through this is we but that's if you
don't need from the get-go you look at
the movie trailer no no I don't so like
it ein you kind of seems I'm sorry you
kind of sue anyone else I alright so
move your appointment I talking about as
plot issues fair enough but it was
alright so this was my other problem
with the revenant which was it like it
is if you were talking about how you
like historical movies movies to create
old ymca like your is that does a
fantastic job of creative this like wild
wet the wild north but went between like
american fur traders French fur traders
Native Americans like it creates this
incredible scene there and sets the
stage and all the Native American tribes
are represented in diverse and
interesting ways I like there's a couple
different factions of play and then they
like have this great chance to make this
drama in this setting with a Native
American League
character and they cast Leo DiCaprio
like it just felt like it was it was
almost there like it could have been
something special but it fell short in a
few ways to me and you know it's a
monumental film in many ways but like a
interesting another one they were kind
of lukewarm a bit on the panel and we've
got two more to get into and the big
short I this is about the financial
crisis obviously another movie about
that believe it's adapted in the same
writer Romani ball and based on a book
as well anyone seen this at all big big
a lot of famous actors and actions in
this one the big short talk segment on
it is going to be a short talks great
all right Megan they go let us know what
you think about the big short and
whether Adam McKay should win best
director or it gets best movie and let
us know in the comments below and I
guess the last movie this is one that I
watched recently and Michael sugars up
for win on this for best film I am
really heard of it until quite recently
a spotlight this is michael keaton and
friends oh yeah and the i guess the
boston globe's reporting on the child
molestation pat epidemic that was with
the Catholic Church stemming I guess
from what was going on in Boston from
their perspective but then led to what
was essentially a global problem that i
didn't really know much about what was
happening in boston at that time because
ireland was going through the same thing
and really his previous and yet so at
the end of the movie there there is a
part where they show here are the cities
in which they're this was a problematic
amazon oh really yeah and there was like
a bunch like I feel like somewhere close
to a dozen irish times repeat we're in
there as well on all the all the cities
they mentioned a really really great
movie like obviously it's about
something that is incredibly difficult
and heartfelt i think what's interesting
about it is that it is predominantly
told from the from the side of the media
like it they obviously interview victims
and they talked to priests and whatnot
but it is told from the side of we have
this story were researching it where you
know it's like the debt it's happening
around the same times is like in you
know these papers are shutting down like
911 happens in the middle so it doesn't
happen
they don't have this sort of it's not
the right time to publish the story
anymore we're worried about someone else
picking up the story where we need to
get them like it's it's not we're just
reporting on a story this this is the
story that we need to nail the church to
the wall so that doesn't happen again so
it's like it's an incredible story it's
only 12 not protected which I think it's
probably to its credit in a way like in
that way it becomes a little like i
enjoy it more i think more because of
being like involved somewhat in the
price and wanna like i enjoy that aspect
of it at least and I think maybe other
people weren't interested in the process
of price writing might think it's a
little bit self-indulgent with the price
may be a little bit and or like focuses
too much on not enough and the victims
or the reality of the story perhaps but
it's great i really enjoyed it i thought
it was a fantastic it we were saying
about how when a movie doesn't write it
doesn't feel long like this movies i
think it's two hours 10-15 minutes
something in a breeze body was really
wonderful and i never describe when you
watch movie you feel like holy [ __ ] like
that's that's kind of like a that's i'm
glad i watch dash because like this is
something that we should not forget
about yeah this sort of stuff got people
got a way with doing this awful [ __ ] for
let's say centuries I finally get call
dad and you know it's been over a decade
now but lest we not forget important
lessons and those are the movies so I
guess the last question for you guys the
big short mad max fury road Josh Shaw
has sent me a link there are apparently
Miller will be going back and making
more mad max movies article post Reese
more recently so we'll see what so hey
so hey thanks Josh at the big short mad
max fury road brooklyn the Martian the
revenant bridge of spies room spotlight
Peter what gets your win off that list
mad max all right of the half of these
that I've seen Mad Max is my choice for
sure and I really liked spotlight a lot
but of the movies that I've watched here
I'd also saved mad max fury road would
it be [ __ ] great it's an action movie
well that just shows you how good that
movie is on many levels on so many like
like the sort of action the
cinematography the shooting that like
the subtext like everything about it
it's just like they just needed look at
target and then more guitar guy
he married or married one of the what's
your name again i forget the name of one
of the wives I whatever name is she was
Elvis Presley's granddaughter all right
think I'm all right little bit little
endian little dude that guy the little
dude I got a question for you about
these nominees all right I one that was
not missing with that I feel was missing
from the Best Picture nomination list
yeah inside out by Pixar oh yeah you
think I think so I saw that at Pixar and
I sorry god that's just the worst thing
that I've ever said I thought that I
Pixlr okay I'm so sorry i saw that i
mind to say i'm such a big picture fine
i love those movies and i was really
lucky that I got to go see it there I'm
actually I thought that was good I was a
good pics i was a good picture wasn't it
wasn't like it didn't blow my mind me oh
my god all right so i watch this and if
it's not a tumor we're running a bit
late along them okay anyways I think
that the way that this movie is
insightful and illuminating about the
human condition and about human emotion
and about the way emotions work inside
of our brains is phenomenal and I think
that it's you know the stories of
teachers and psychiatrists using it to
like help educate people rise for my
heart but like I watch this with my wife
and her mother and they we like had lost
uh my father-in-law in the past couple
years and like this like the way that
that movie deals with like grief and
sadness and it was like we were all it
we discussed it afterwards and like how
how true was in our lives then you know
how it resonates with stuff that we
encountered our childhood it just the
the writing and the way that they
brought its life i thought was
phenomenal and worthy of high praise and
we've already run over super long in
this but I think that we can't talk
about this without also talking about
what's happening I in relation to you
know with not not to say that like this
is something we should only talk about
on Martin Luther King weekend but
especially and with everything that's
happening at the moment sort of around
the country obviously there's a lot of
eyes on the fact that this is a super
white nominees list across the board
jada pinkett smith and Spike Lee are
going to not be attending the Oscars and
the Oscar the economy is put at its own
press release about this and you know
we're three white guys here we're not
the people to be really talking about
this but let's just take a moment and
say like
water there were some really great
movies starring african-american actors
or some about african-american stories
which did not get highlighted this year
and the ones I sort of started to me I
think we're looking at at the moment is
Creed which I did not see a lot of
people telling me that this is not just
a great Rocky movie but this is a great
movie yeah mr. you seen it yeah yeah I
really liked it a guide the kind of like
the old Mad Max films the Rocky films
for me were like this little joke that
you do like reference once in a while
yeah just go back to you to have it
laughs kind of hokey but have fun and
great yeah this this was like a solid
like you know kind of coming-of-age
story from this kid who grew up like in
the splendor of his father's success
figuring out who he was and finding his
own success in defining that in his own
terms and then sort of linking back to
this old series and it did it in a way
that wasn't really like ham-fisted like
Rocky was this really like this dude
with problems you know yeah like he's by
the end of the movie he's still not
resolved his issues and but that's fine
because Michael B Jordan the the kid who
played Adonis Creed was so good like at
his role is so believable hmm and so
good as as a companion like with his
girlfriend I thought that was a really
honest relationship and it was
interesting to see that blossom
alongside this sort of like film that's
based on fighting a couple of other
movies of people have been pointing at
beasts of no nation and I haven't seen
yet but when I did see as a massive NWA
fun i was actually kind of a little
worried about this i thought i go you
know they're gonna to kind of a weird
story to try and tell especially like
you're gonna use you know I x singer is
like the person who's in the movie sons
of players just so much about Straight
Outta Compton seemed like it wasn't
going to work man this was a [ __ ]
solid movie I like absolutely adored the
Chris did you see no unfortunately I
Peter view seen it it's super cry while
I watched it up I wash it on a plane and
on the way back fix our private jet I
thought it was amazing you know
Giamatti's in it and and it's got a but
like all all the actors in it playing it
what it did actually was tell a side of
that sorry I didn't realize because I
was so young when all
was happening and I sort of was and away
found after the fact was that man they
were so young like those dudes were were
like straight out of school like they
were just they were still teenagers
there was the young man when I was
happening and I guess the sort of the
movement that they that they lit was
didn't seem weird to them because that
was the reality they were living in but
it seemed weird to the rest of the world
right so like it was it wasn't like
there were some revolutionaries who were
taking this dangerous idea and trying to
force it on people that was just the
reality they lived in and it seemed
completely normal for them to talk about
it and I think as somebody who sort of
only ever saw one side of that
conversation through their music to sort
of see what I saw in this movie wasn't
just an echo of their music it was
actually really put in context to what
was happening during that time which
someone especially growing up in Ireland
who didn't really know a lot about and
you know civil rights movement or about
the sort of Rodney King episodes and all
that sort of stuff it was definitely
growing up it was like a massive massive
insight into that world and it's still
kind of [ __ ] sucks right that like
they were watching me like Selma was an
arm of your watch recently watching all
these movies about these you know these
poignant times in the world where we've
learned lessons in the same way that
like I was watching a movie about
Catholic priests getting away with
molesting you know like movies about
these times but like literally it's
still like when we're talking about it
like it's like art and life or just like
it's like it's almost ridiculous but you
know we're in the situation and I'm sure
the Academy is full of a lot of you know
old Hollywood people know you're talking
predominantly Caucasian predominantly
male so it's sort of a shame that we're
not like in the UK they have the the
mobile words which is like specifically
to highlight people of colors arts and
music specifically and we don't you know
that's probably not the right way to go
about doing this other stuff but like
you kind of feel for all these artists
when they're making all this stuff and
it doesn't get recognized just because
people aren't in touch with it they'd
only see it it just seems to me like you
know you you know I were all white dudes
here right you know we're used to seeing
our Saturnalia we're used to seeing
ourselves represented in a variety of
ways you know there's not just like the
the one like one or two great white do
good movies this year like there's a lot
yeah because such a lion's share of
movies are made with white dudes in like
really prominent roles I think that when
you hear people talking especially women
and people of color talking about how
representation matters to them and being
represented in you know on screen in
awards how that's so vital and so
important you can't ignore that you have
to listen you have to trust that that is
that that is a real powerful thing
because it's not something I've ever
struggled with being able to look at a
screen and see an image of myself or an
image of how I might imagine myself like
an alien concept yeah it's just not so
so to me I trust those people and I
trust that that you know that and I read
what they say and it's compelling and
it's heartbreaking and then you go turn
around and see Star Wars and it's two
stars of that a woman and a black guy
and they are fantastic and sure say what
you will about Star Wars being the name
is to associated with it but like that
movie is great because those two are
great in it and like that's you know a
money money talks all right well money
is talking's you know like let's not
meet use that argument anymore for sure
vegas movie opening of all time they
boom that's you know see what happens
interesting was that snubbed actually
last point on this star wars since you
bring it up Oh for best film yeah it's
pretty good film I don't know it's a
real mean it's better than had a great
time better than the Martian let us know
in the comments if you think Star Wars
The Force awakens is better than the
Martian and yeah let us know what you
think about the nominees what you think
is gonna win and what do you think yeah
some movies are maybe you liked the
warrant and mentioned at all in the in
the nominations let us know in the
comments below all right I run out a
little bit but I was fun I mean we took
on a big topic let's be real that's true
yeah I was not talking about the best
movies of the year there's a lot of
movies I know I was like saying I will
only talk about best movies you want to
talk about like actors nominees or
cinematography running it'll be super
short no problem and then I came in and
I have like my whole nominee list here
and I'm scrolling back more than like oh
yeah yeah sound editing room like a
great to have you hit that last question
is get yo getting at his best actor
award wait is he not 14 no he's never
gone in Oscar
[ __ ] stop trying he shouldn't for this
yeah you know man you shouldn't just
like didn't dig it into a bad job in the
movie by any stretch but it just feels
like do the beach too as your as a
novelist beached more Beach hard with a
vengeance